and he spoke for almost an hour and a
half and the crowd
aided up the president not giving up the
fight
we have a lot to get to tonight analysis
coming you do not want to touch that
dial
and now resisting ruin
that's the focus of tonight's angle
now tonight the focus returns to where
it needs to be
an all-out effort to prevent the
far-left radicals that comprise today's
democrat party
from destroying the country we love now
as the president
just made clear tonight it is all on the
line in georgia
re-election of republican senators
purdue and leffler
it's absolutely critical these really
could be the most important senate
elections in recent memory at least my
lifetime
a 50-50 tie in the senate will ensure
an all-out assault on our freedoms our
economy
and our constitution including our
second amendment
and our religious liberty in the first
amendment now warnock and ossif
will be the senate version when you
really think about it of the squad
total nightmares and while republicans
they've been engaging at times in kind
of a pointless circular firing squad
routine democrats
they were busy registering new voters
and ramping up interest in the runoffs
in normal times republicans usually fare
better in runoffs but these are not
normal times
this is why mega mega turnout
is imperative tomorrow now will the rnc
deliver at the polls
we're going to find out just how good
their organization is
but i will tell you this this is no
time to sit on the sidelines or to stay
home and
complain and moan about how unfair
everything is
or how lame republican state officials
are set it all aside
and keep your eye on resisting the rise
of the rabid socialists
who will run you over while they'll
enrich wall street and
china so my conclusion
everyone needs to get out and vote not
just
you go out and vote you need to get like
10 other people
to go to the polls with you tomorrow
vote like your life depends on it
because it does